DESTIN>> That's right You stand on the right
Hey it's me Destin welcome back to Smarter Every Day, I'm teaching my kids that you're supposed to stand on the right. Stand on the right.
He's standing.. she's there.. you go. All right we're in Detroit and we came here to see
the American Record for Dominoes
toppling
we're really excited about it. There's a young lady on YouTube her name is Lily and we watch her videos and we came to learn
about dominoes. But first we're in the Detroit airport so you have to see this fountain. What do you call this flow?
That flow right there.
SON>> Laminar flow.
What's it called?
CHILDREN>> Laminar flow.
DESTIN>> Laminar flow. Some Daddies don't teach their kids cool words like this
SON>> Oh, I already know "Alias"
DESTIN>> Yeah?
SON>> And all that other stuff.
You don't you don't appreciate this
What you don't appreciate laminar flow. I choose
To believe that it's not that the laminar flow doesn't impress them, it's that they were turbo
Excited that we got there a day early in detroit so we could see a Behind-The-Scenes look at the largest domino fall in American History
Seriously, these videos get millions of views online but you don't get to see the people behind it and how much care and time they
Put into it. That's why we came to Detroit a day early. Oh my goodness.
This is it ? Okay so you're Lily?
LILY>> Yes, I'm Lily.
DESTIN>> i'm Destin Nice to meet you. Alright so i don't -
I'm too scared to move anywhere. Where do we - Where do we go?
>> You can stay outside of the Caution tape
DESTIN>> Outside of The Caution tape.
LILY>> Walk along here.
DESTIN>> okay... this is way...
Way more impressive in person
You Know what i mean?
LILY>> Yeah it's different when you actually see it live
DESTIN>> Yeah, like I've seen - i've seen your videos - a lot of your videos but this is
Insane. This is what you did for us.
That's crazy. So this is the night before the competition or it's not a competition.
LILY>> It's an event.
DESTIN>> It's an event.
STEVE>> Or a demonstration
DESTIN>> A demonstration? Ok
STEVE>> By the way, we have the Floor Plan right here.
DESTIN>> That's the Floor Plan?
STEVE>> Yeah i designed the setup this year.
DESTIN>> Oh Wow!
If somebody were to mess up and knock over one thing, how do you keep It from from moving on to the other ones?
You've gotta have like - There's got to be a Domino Builder terminology, like Safeties or
LILY>> We call it Safety Gap where you take like six dominoes out and
Because there's a gap if you knock it down, it'll stop at the gap
and we do...
DESTIN>> Is that what that is right there?
LILY>> Yeah right there in the corner
You'll see if it if it falls this way it won't continue
So at the end we just fill in all the gaps very carefully and this way
Just like a small portion of the domino setup will be toppled if we do knock it down by accident
Instead of the whole thing.
DESTIN>> And this is like - This is your "thing", right?
This is What you're good at
BOTH>> Yeah
DESTIN>> How long have you guys been working together?
STEVE>> Three years now. Yeah we've each been building for over ten years. we've been working together for
three Years and we've done lots of
professional projects for companies where we build advertisements, logos, and things like that
DESTIN>> Will you walk me through what we have right now
Steve and Lilly showed me around the entire set up and seriously, please go check out that video on the second channel. It's an awesome
Behind-The-Scenes tour of the whole set up. Every little thing... It's amazing, you're gonna like it.
I learned tons of Domino Builders secrets that I had never thought about before. For example these guys make custom tools out of Lego so they can
Speed up the process and make nice neat lines. Check out how they make pictures. Steve wrote an entire computer program that would translate
Pixels into dominoes. The next day, we got there early and got to meet the entire team
On the count of three, say your name. One two three...
(names)
Yeah, nice to meet you. So anyway how many hours do you think, like Man-Hours/Woman-Hours, do you think this represents?
STEVE>> Seven days times 12 hours
(Mumbling)
Domino People are very precise people so you can't just ask a question and get a quick answer you have to get the actual answer
1512 hours
There's two American Records in this particular Fall right?
STEVE>> Three.
DESTIN>> Three? Yeah okay what are they?
STEVE>> Okay so the first one is
Most total dominoes toppled in America.
DESTIN>> Just like in General General?
STEVE>> Yep in one complete Fall Down. The second American Record is
The domino - largest domino field
DESTIN>>That's the White rain there right?
STEVE>> So That's the Pokemon Field That Has Over
12,000 dominoes
DESTIN>> Okay
STEVE>> And The Third record is the largest
Domino structure in America which is game over which is the finale.
DESTIN>> So That's - That's the largest
Three-dimensional wall structure in America?
STEVE>> Yep, but that also has over
12,000 dominoes.
DESTIN>> So this is pretty fun. You get all these people showing up to see this and then you get the Dominoe
Team over there
They're getting in the zone. It's really fun to watch.
What do you think?
LILY>> I Feel amazing. This toppled without any breaks at all and I'm just i'm so happy right now
DESTIN>> Oh wait so so you said every 60 dominoes is one second.
STEVE>> Yep.
DESTIN>> Really? Is that is that a constant?
STEVE>> No it's not a constant.
DESTIN>> What do you mean?
STEVE>> It really depends on a lot of different things like
The friction on the floor is probably the biggest thing
The spacing of the dominoes is another thing obviously. When they're more far apart they fall slower and
Some of the European Builders actually have this theory that different colors fall at different speeds.
DESTIN>> European Builders think different colours fall at different speeds.
STEVE>> It could be due to the paint being different or the colouring, the dye, whatever is used. It could have slightly different mass
Maybe that's it
DESTIN>> Okay, will you send me different color dominoes and build me a gauge stick so i could do it in a High-Speed video?
Okay i'm in the garage, we're about to do a domino motion analysis. I want you to look at Trent's hat look at this hat
Do you like it?
It's great. It looks like something you would wear wherever you're doing domino motion Analysis okay so
Here is the High-speed camera. What we're gonna do is -
This is what i call the Swagger Stick that Steve sent me it's an index so you can set up the dominoes and
Set them up the same every time
We've got a ruler for motion Analysis here and
we can change out the type of material that we're knocking the domino's over on. We've got different kinds of
felts and things like that, we've got this dry erase board, we've got some metal down here... We're gonna look at all the variables
TRENT>> Here we go
DESTIN>> And we're going in
It's pivoting about.. That's - what - exactly what it's doing
Oh dude i just had the moment where it all clicks. It's - it's rotating about the center of gravity
It's exactly what's happening. As it's falling you have translation and rotation and so that front edge is a pivot point
But if there's not enough friction.. are you seeing it? Yeah, it's - it's trying to rotate about its center of gravity
If there's not enough friction.
Let's put the foam or paper towel down so it can't slip and it's not gonna rotate.
That's gonna translate more of that energy forward isn't it?
So it's faster on a grippy surface. No? Yeah?
On the felt surface the bottom of the domino is slipping backwards again but it catches due to higher friction.
So the question is, because it's slipping less, does that mean the whole line is going to topple forward faster?
So just did a hard plastic and a clear plastic
side-by-side and right at the end you can see, it's very very clear...
It's very clear there's a difference. Back it up, back it up. Did you see the clear in the back?
The clear plastic ones kick out more so maybe yhey're slower
Do you want a domino to grip or not grip? Dunno...
So clear dominoes are heavier
And they go faster. That - that is counterintuitive. So it's 4 A.M.
Smarter Every Midnight
Okay look I feel like I owe you an apology because on Smarter Every Day when I break out the High-Speed camera
It's like the mysteries of the Universe are revealed but when I turn it on this little block of
Plastic. We only get more questions. For example the first 20 dominoes in our setup - it's
Accelerating so we're not getting a steady state velocity of the topple until after that so i think
My setup is inadequate to do what we're trying to do. I mean, also the fact that this thing
Doesn't pivot like a hinge like every research paper says it does, it slips
we're in an area of Physics now called Tribology which is the study of two frictional services in relative motion.
This is complicated. There's a lot more Greek letters in the math now
Another thing, like right here, the way I've been triggering this, I've been touching that
That's inconsistent how I'm doing that. If you have better ideas I
Feel like we need to redo this entire setup and do it right so
If you would leave comments below on ideas for how to trigger that,
Things on the setup, I want to do this right but for right now I mean we've done complicated things on Smarter Every Day
But the simple domino, the
Simple domino is a challenge. It's hard stuff
Did you know that each time you buy a Casper you get a free time machine?
SON>> WHAT?
DESTIN>> I want to thank the sponsor for today's video which is Casper. You can get a mattress at casper.com/smarter
Tara and I have slept on a Casper for over two years
Everybody asks me face to face "are you just saying that on YouTube or do you actually like it?"
Of course I actually like it which is why I got one for the guest bedroom
Which my daughter took over
Now we have one for the boys. So if you want a mattress go to casper.com/smarter use the promo code smarter to
Get $50 off. There's a lot of cool things about it they'll ship it directly to your house you get to open it up it's kind of fun.
Also you get to bypass the mattress company in the middleman so you get
a high quality mattress for a less expensive price. It's a good thing. There's multiple types of foam so you get the right balance between comfort and
Support without it being too hot and you get a hundred nights free trial if you don't like it, they'll come pick it up at
Your house you don't have to worry about it. This is my favorite part. I'm not just saying this, I actually do like the product
and when you support the sponsor
You support Smarter Every Day which allows me to do things like support the Zeal Incredible Science Machine which is a really cool way
for really neat smaller YouTube channels like Lily and Steve
To create videos that they love. They make good stuff. I think the reason it's so good is because they are
Seriously passionate about dominoes and that is contagious.
It's your support of the sponsors that make that sort of thing happen so thank you very much. Also
Go check out that video in the second Channel. It is rad. It's a long video
But I learned stuff I have never ever thought about in my entire life. New stacking methods, how they index them, the speed of dominoes?
It's really fun I think you'll really enjoy it. Feel free to subscribe if this earned it, if not
No big deal i'm Destin and you're getting Smarter Every Day. Have a good one now.
Thank you very much for letting me do that so this you did that last year
too right?
LILY>> Yep
DESTIN>> You know i'm actually changing the logo on Smarter Every Day after this video.
This video is like the last video using this logo. It's going to be something similar.